everybody it's gary vaynerchuck
garyvaynerchuk.com as you can see to
show it I feel a little tasting video
about to be done and actually I'm here
on vacation with the family but I wanted
to pump out another video because I'm on
this hot kick thinking about really
getting back into video on GV comm not
an actual URL and I'm reading this book
about the history of ESPN on this
vacation because I need to read
something otherwise my head goes into
business mode and it's not a vacation I
get frustrated and want to build 800
businesses
unfortunately for me ESPN's book about
its history is very business oriented
and I'm in part of the book right now
where they brought in some professional
people from McKinley and consulting and
new CEOs and things that nature and the
conversation is about how they realized
that ESPN was not going to be able to
succeed in the early 80s mid 80s at this
point in the book with it only being
supported by ad revenue that they
realized that I had to go to the cable
providers interesting enough first was
cable vision and the Dolans that they
were able to pay get them to pay for the
right person scriber for the right to
have ESPN and then kind of meeting that
and then opening up the headlines about
Hulu being shopped today a lot of talk
about Apple buying Hulu and I kind of
sat there and said huh you know
ad-supported you know talking about
subscription I'm obsessed with freemium
I'm working on my wine videos that I do
now a freemium model and daily Graper
it's a newsletter driven thing and
transparently I'm debating if I want to
still do it
because you know it's a lot of time and
can I justify the cost and the value and
really got me to a place of like is the
Internet video space which clearly
hasn't gotten its [ __ ] together all the
way and justified its cost yeah other
successes that revision3 but you know
you know has it really gotten there
we've seen next new networks sell but it
was to youtube more to be like kind of
like infrastructure for their YouTube
celebrities and it's been interesting
outside of like YouTube celebrities that
are able to really kind of justify
through ad revenue along with YouTube
supporting that is there going to be a
time are we looking at a place where
people are gonna need to charge for
their videos if it is of quality content
are the big nations are the Lorne
Feldman's
are the people out there going to be
able to get to a place where they charge
99 cents per video 5 bucks a month are
we looking at the internet videos
in a very similar place to where cable
television was in the mid 80s when
people realized huh
this isn't supported just by ad revenue
do we need subscription-based models and
so I'm very curious as we now go into a
culture where Apple established us for
paying in micro payments for apps taking
away what was three you know content
free applications free games on the
internet
years ago now we're paying $0.99 two
three bucks for these applications these
apps on mobile is this gonna bleed into
a world where video content is going to
have to go through a similar business
route I think it's a fascinating debate
and I would love to get your two cents
on it